come on innovations my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the major problems in the world
so Helen on your journey today we're
going to talk about how you can create a
massive action rule number three is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best and as
always as you're watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the count's below
book quotes around other people to be
inspiring might win a prize too and i'll
see when you write it down it's much
more likely the stick for yourself as
well
[Music]
some of you in the past you've gotten
momentum you've gotten passionate you've
even made a decision but a decision is
the first step decision is like a war I
gotta do this or that all right I'm
gonna make myself do this but commitment
is when you now after you've decided you
commit to do this for the long term
whether it's hard or easy doesn't matter
you're doing this it takes it from this
moment and it carries you to the future
even when things are difficult then once
you decide the only way the commitment
and the energy and the momentum
continues is if you take immediate
massive what my friends massive life
write down in your notes massive action
is the cure-all massive action is the
cure-all if you're having a difficult
time with something your relationship
isn't where you want it to be your
finances are not where you want to be
your body's not where you want to be
your business is not where it want to be
you need take massive action and if that
doesn't work try something else so
that's just work try something else keep
going with massive action and you will
find the way because it will give you
momentum
when it comes to planning your life I
want to get to learn to ask three
questions now and the first one is not
what am I gonna do and how many
understand why now say I the question
wanna ask yourself is what do I want
what's my outcome what's my result the
word are p.m. the first one is to get
you focused on the target the target is
not the activity the activity can change
it's what the what's the result I'm
after if you know exactly what it is you
really want what you desire what you're
really after clarity is power the more
clear you aren't specifically what you
want the faster your brain can get you
there
but if you're generally saying things
like what I want well yeah I want more
money fine here's a dollar get out of
here did you achieve the outcome yeah
when you're that general you maybe you
think you're not getting your goal you
are the way you language your goal the
way you think about it you're receiving
it you know you know I you know I want
to feel a bit better I want to lose some
weight
fine you lost the pound you're done
because your brains like a
servomechanism
and a bomb and a missile the old days
you shoot a missile and the target was
going and if you missed the trajectory
you missed it today what happens when
the missile is not on course what
happens
it locks under the heat signature what
to do it moves and follows it that's the
way your brain is if it knows the
outcome if it knows the result so rpm
starts with I got another result this is
a results planning system the rapid
planning method but you can think of it
as a results planning system I even know
the result I'm after before I ever asked
myself what to do that takes more time
but it's worth it and when you think in
terms of outcomes in that activities
pretty soon some of the activities
you'll need me to do to get the outcome
you find a better way to get the outcome
quicker now how do you do that yes three
questions question one what is my result
was my outcome what is that I really
truly want from this if you're going
back next week he said this next week
one of the most important what outcomes
for me to get this week in my business
he is right those outcomes out not your
action items the outcomes you if you do
that nothing else you'll be ahead of the
game and if you just keep looking at
those outcomes every day how am i doing
on that outcome your brain will come up
with ways to get
to that outcome I promise you focus on
outcomes not on activities action for
most people activities most people may
mistake movement for achievement they
mistake action items and to dues for
achievement we're after the achievement
are you with me on this yes or no it's a
different way of thinking and I think
all of you inherently have it but if you
make this ritualized just like the
things you've learned this week they're
all great but if you don't systematize
them they'll work when you do them why
is more important than how why are we
doing this what's the purpose purpose is
more powerful than object purposes on
top of an object you say I want a
million dollars that's a great objective
I want a billion dollars great objective
I want to feed three thousand children
in my community as a beautiful
objectives even more specific but even
that objective you might get excited
about she runs when it takes to feed
three thousand kids right and the
politics involved and all the people
that don't follow through and then you
have this good intention then somebody's
else's just off because one of the kids
didn't get fed right and you didn't you
know how to do what's gonna make you
keep going purpose why do you want to
see those 3,000 kids why do you want to
make that million dollars that billion
dollars why are you gonna take your
business the next level why is the most
important thing to know because that's
where all the emotional juice and fuel
is to actually get you to go through and
the challenges show up every person you
see who's on fired and successful knows
the line you know the problem is you
might know the why the beginning you're
at a mission state and stuff like that
you don't know why you're doing this
right now this right now
that's what's gonna gauge you and
activate the why you might have a why
but it's not active 80 percent of
success is why 20 percent is how did a
big enough why people figure out how to
do it so what's another why we know what
you're after and why and the question is
how do we do it we know what we're after
why how do we do it but other lots of
house to get to an outcome yes or no
are there many paths to get a result yes
or no some are more efficient than
others and you're not gonna now so you
brainstorm on all the house you can
think of all the things you could
possibly need to do to get that result
me and there are downs the 20% that
makes 80% of the difference and you'll
find out you don't have to do that all
to delist
that wouldn't be nice to write your all
to do this and not do it and still get
the outcome I don't get to her that say
that's our p.m. I love it when I don't
do my to Do's and I got the outcome
that's the coolest thing in the world
you might done one or two of them but
it's been learning selectively which
ones are gonna create it but the only
way need us to brainstorm out the end
that the massive action plan so if you
know the result and your the purpose now
you need the animal just the massive
action plan we also called massive
action plan on the map your massive
action plan you're not probably gonna
get there by the way when you crystal
clear what you want and you know why you
want it you can make a big map you can
bring some a million ways to do it
not all your house are gonna work that's
why you make a whole map and then go
back and gradually Asterix the ones that
are the most important go hit dumps you
might get the whole outcome in the first
two action items to get rid of your
whole rush to your list this is our p.m.
this is how I operate never give you
some paper you just did this thinking
process in your head you'll get
invaluable resources if you learn to put
this on paper and be more powerful
because then your brain isn't racing and
you can see it if you're making you a
system that you personally use your
productivity will explode if you teach
your whole company to this your company
will go over levels you can't even
imagine this everyone will maximize
their productivity
large uninterrupted blocks of time you
have to schedule if you are creator
blocks of time that are at least two to
four hours or more
no Frankenstein monster of 20 minute
breaks and ten minute breaks combined
into three hours will have the value of
an uninterrupted block of three hours if
you are trying to make high-level
decisions focus on time-consuming
high-priority projects push something to
a next milestone as a maker creator we
all have the same 24 hours in the day
and if you're like I don't have time I
can't sleep I need to cut back on sleep
I need to do this I need to do that if
you don't have time you don't have
priorities that's it
writing in a journal allows you to
record your daily progress there's a lot
of scientific research on the small wind
theory and what it says is this if every
single day you record small daily acts
of progress you actually dump dopamine a
neurotransmitter into your brain and
that is a great source of motivation you
feel happy and you feel strong and you
feel inspired so every single morning in
your holy hour from 5 to 6 take 20
minutes record your wins of the previous
day in your journal
it'll keep you motivated it'll make you
feel like you're making progress
it'll keep you inspired versus always
feeling like you're never achieving this
what do you suggest Mel for accessing
what you really want you know I talk a
lot about being honest with yourself
about what you want and if you're
somebody that's watching this and you
have no clue what you want I'm gonna say
that's total bullsh I think you've
probably decided that either you can't
have it because you don't think you're
smart enough or good enough or worthy
enough so maybe you think you're too old
or you've told yourself that you can't
make a living doing it both are complete
and utter lies that you're telling
yourself what you need to do is ask
yourself this if you took money off the
table if you didn't give what anybody
else thought what's the thing you would
love to be doing with your life
seriously do you dream of being a
professional photographer you want to
open your own restaurant you always
thought about traveling the world and
entertaining kids with your juggling
skills I don't know it's your life you
get to choose what you want to do be
honest with yourself
what is it that you would want to do
with
your life if you didn't have to pay the
bills doing it another thing you can ask
yourself who do you find yourself sort
of envious of you know like you look at
their life and you just think gosh how
awesome that they get to do that well
once you have that answer for yourself
you've gotten really honest you push the
[ __ ] aside and you've really asked
it for yourself and answered the
question honestly all you got to do is
explore it that's it just find one thing
that you can do to enrich and expand
your knowledge about it find one course
online google the topic stalk people
that are pursuing this line of work
that's how you start to do it one step
at a time
so start with answering the question
what do you really want with a massive
dose of honesty google the topic and
find one thing that you can do just one
push yourself and start to explore it if
you were to wake up and do that every
single day spend ten minutes a day you
would be startled astonished by what
your life looks like in a matter of a
year or two never lose hope that that
you have a single breath within your
body right now and that you are alive in
this moment is hope that you can see all
these people walking on the street
smiling is is hope that all these
entrepreneurs are posting their art
online every single day now there is
hope there that there's a single person
out in this world whose soul is still
burning alive with love is hope you know
it's so easy during these days when
sometimes there's darkness when you see
all this negative media coverage or
maybe you have a series of bad days or
series of bad weeks or you're your lucky
break just isn't coming or you've been
fighting for that dream you just don't
sense any of that progress that you just
so need to feel still enliven and engage
and enthusiastic about something or
somebody breaks up with you or you lose
your job or something happens with your
health look that's part of life is
there's gonna be so many struggles and
disappointments challenges
Bax dark days and part of sustaining and
making through all of that is
maintaining hope and that hope isn't
something that just you know some
airy-fairy concept it is a psychological
need to believe that we can endure a
psychological need to believe that we
can not only endure but we can succeed
and we can thrive and we can have our
way in the world so that we can
accomplish our dream so that we can make
influence we can make our own difference
so have hope but even as I say that let
me reconfigure that statement and that
phrase because too many people say well
you have hope or you can lose hope but
hope isn't something actually you have
or that you lose even though we say that
phrase in such a popular level you know
years ago a metaphor came into my life
that changed my life forever
it changed my my attitude and my actions
and and how I thought about life and
frankly how I felt every single moment
of the day it was something that lifted
me to hold a level of joy and vibrancy
in life and it was this very simple
metaphor that the power plant doesn't
have energy it transforms and generates
energy we say that again the power plant
doesn't have energy it transforms and
generates energy at the same level
we don't quote have hope we transform
the energy around us we generate hope we
don't have happiness we generate
happiness similarly we don't have
sadness or fatigue we don't have those
those feelings that so many people think
are negative that just land on them that
we are in our own actions our own
thoughts our own interpretations the
very thoughts that we are feeding are
our psyche those very things those are
generating an emotion and hope is
something that is generated by us when
it feels like it is gone that becomes a
to-do list for us to generate it once
more just like when your phone is dying
you plug it in to charge it up well when
your hope is
it's time to generate it and charge it
up again same thing with happiness and
aliveness an enthusiasm
those are things when they're going down
you got to get focused you got to plug
back in to your passions to your dreams
to tomorrow to charge yourself back up
again
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what did you think of this
video what did you take from it that
you're going to immediately apply to
your life or to your business somehow
please share leave it there in the
comments below I'm really excited to see
what you have I also want to give a
quick chef to act on there some
marketing thank you so much for making a
copy of my book your one word and
sharing the post that I've made on
Twitter about it I really appreciate the
support and I hope you enjoy thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you bucatini to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
have an amazing day and I'll see
in describing your values you prefer to
use verbs over nouns now why is this the
case and what words chief what verbs do
you use to describe yourself so values
have to be verbs it's not that I like
them to be verbs it's that they have to
be verbs and the reason is because
values are things you do values the
things you live by and you can't do
nouns you can only do verbs and so if
you look at an organization for example
you know you see companies that have
their corporate values on the wall and
it says innovation respect honesty right
now it's nice posters you know your
beautiful posters yeah and if you have
to write honesty on the wall you've got
bigger problems you know but you can't
do innovation you can't walk into
someone's office and say from now on
please a little more innovation and
although in all that you do but you can
say look at the world from a different
perspective instead of innovation you
instead of honesty you can say do the
right thing you can hold people
accountable to that you can create
measurements around that and when
somebody says you know what was your
were you honest be like well yeah but
you know was more profitable you know
you can sort of sneak around of where
somebody says did you do the right thing
it's a higher standard and so you have
to have verbs if you want to do them so
my values are taken on conventional
perspective keep it simple
share I believe in sharing everything
sharing ideas sharing experiences
Silverline it and what I mean by that is
I find the silver lining in every cloud
the goal is not to try and fix the
things that are broken the goal is to
try and amplify the things that work and
ultimately one of the goals is make
long-term progress and because that is a
stated value a stated way of operating
and and it is a verb it I focus on
measuring the long-term value I can
create in the world and not just the
short-term gains first you sit or lie in
a quiet place where you can be
completely alone in the silence through
positive affirmations imagine yourself
going through an important upcoming
experience such as a meeting a
presentation and negotiation or even a
date
that would improve your work-life
balance and your quality of life
as you sit or lie completely relaxed
create a picture of the coming event and
see it unfolding perfectly in every
respect see yourself is calm positive
happy and in complete control see the
other people doing and saying exactly
what you would want them to do if the
situation was perfect